Mollie Kuramoto liable catalyzed make
sure that you try these supplements out
there very very good very healthy
natural and you can check the link in
the description box that is nature's
blend black seed oil and they have other
things as well oh yeah a little boy boy
boy hope you enjoy the video so this
first can't be talking about you know
why because the narrative is juices
right he's the second coming of Jesus
this is Jesus in the verse that's
talking there's going to be a prefer
after me called amp so he's the French
in this verse this Jesus Christ is
differentiating between himself and
damnit do you see this point because
Jesus insane embodies Muhammad there's
going to be a prophet after me called
Ahmed and it's not him and it's not a
sir it's a different individual
completely docile said about the
latter-day Messiah right so that's him
but then the moment also prophesied in
the Koran that the latter day Messiah
will come believe it just it's just a
person that that is we believe is Kalam
emit you guys believe it's because era
because he says death right it can be
ISA or again right cuz in the Quran
itself all messengers before the holy
prophet of nine with respect the over
all due respect even if we took even if
we take your interpretation of that
seriously and that Jesus is dead yeah
let's take your interpretation seriously
even if Jesus is dead it doesn't mean
that the person that has to be the next
Messiah is gonna be a map so the result
then we start talking about like the
character ray of the promised Messiah
I'm sorry
because our time with the character and
the signs in the ground that showed that
use ones can give me some idea
truthfulness right but right he's known
as a truthful person right not like the
criteria or somebody to be composite
right which worse are you talking about
I think it's from the Hatice actually
alright so it directly corresponds to
the Quran wreck it doesn't contradict
this I understand what you say you
confuse I understand you look like
you're honest and genuine I'm humble
individual and I respect the fact that
he's taking the time to come and ask me
these questions I really do I'm gonna
give you two or three evidences I think
which means that they don't actually
allow anyone to have any I want you to
come see me by all means come recluses
that's not a problem because I don't
have to give my number to people what's
up with all due respect I've got a lot
of people what Atkins you know but if
someone wants to if someone was to speak
to me I'm gonna be in the conference
tonight so you can come to the
conference he's welcome to the
conference okay and if you want to have
a discussion with me after the
conference
consider this a public and you either go
tell him right yeah cuz yeah I don't
want to waste time with anyone
right we consider this a public
invitation I'm saying consider a public
invitation okay a public invitation for
you your your friend that you're
considering a scholar yeah he's a
scholar in the Hadees so you know fine
obviously I can't nope it's not about
being you bro finally the true facility
even if I don't approve you right I
couldn't right yeah it's not it's
alright if you had the truth and I
didn't I would not be able to prove you
wrong if I tried to prove to you that
two plus two equals five whatever
however clever I am it's not gonna work
because no one's gonna believe it I
think this is less complicated because
you have a prophet saying let there be a
body there's no prefer to me you have in
the Quran it says Ottoman Navy in that
he's the fine no profit no just so it's
to Christ there's a long time that's to
you there's to your heart I'm a seal and
heart Tim is final seal bro do you know
the phrase oh there's two Korat you can
recite it as hot n and hot Tim hard time
means the seal of the prophets heart Tim
means the final prophet heart it means
your is the final one unless someone
wants to say I don't believe in that
Quran in that case I'll say if that
person says I'm sorry to say because the
Quran says if I taught me no know about
leaky tabby or check for an IV Bob do
you believe in Plus of the book and
disbelieve in parts of the book so you
believe in it when it's in line with
your with what scholars say and you just
believe in it when it's more in line
with and that's what the Quran says it
Taliban al bab has been duly level mercy
happy no Maryam Allah since that they've
taken the rabbi's in the priests as God
to precise a lot and I said no Maria so
as far as not to fall into that category
of people and then I'd even had him who
who was an extra Sein
he said we didn't used to take her who
didn't used to say Carabas amongst as
gods besides God then the Prophet said
to him did they not make Hallel what
alarm it's Haram and make her a llama
Talon and they said he said yeah so the
point is is that you've all got to be
clear we speaking to Christians with a
look for example truly is not mentioned
in your Bible co-equal co-channel
persons of the Trinity you know this was
the development that came 300 years
after which they show us something
concrete within your own unpreserved
texts we're saying we're even better
than look we have the same preserved
text look ucky me and you have preserved
text they don't have preserved text
we agree with the anus Allah we have a
perfect it's a perfect book and is
preserved no one can say this verse is
not meant to be recited like that if I
say heart him unless why if someone says
yeah so if someone says this there's
only two you can't have a different
interpretation I'm saying this I'm
saying that if this are these are the
two only ways to reciting at verse 10
and hurt him
yeah hard time means the seal you're
right I agree with you
ha Tim means their final like for
example you can recite you know malakoma
dean malakoma team is the owner of the
day of judgment
Mele Chioma Dean sick one forgot family
this is it malakoma Deen means owner of
the day of judgment Malek Yama team
malakoma team means the king of the day
of judgment now if someone says I don't
believe that Allah is the king of the
day of judgment I don't believe that
I'll say why are you disbelieving in to
us I say Mele kill me Dean I think the
Sony verse from Quran Allah says Allah
is the owner yeah so you believe this is
haunted so hot it is preserved yes you
know you're not gonna say that the word
heart him is unpreserved the one's heart
him and heart and both of them are
preserved Plus Alliance preserve pipe if
if hearten is preserved and the Quran is
preserved
there's only one more thing you can do
now you have to go into the books of the
Arabs the three Arabs the poetry the
power miss Oracle the dictionaries and
find me anyone that says heart him does
not mean the final if you find that
allow shake your hand and agree with you
but if you can't find that then we must
agree the Quran is explicit and is
unequivocal and it's unambiguous and is
completely clear in the fact that the
Quran says ha Tim which means the final
not only hot ember hurt him you see the
point here this is a lie it is an
impossible verse to translate the other
way cut him yeah
I'm selling you a key I've done the
research I can't
for to make a mistake do you know how
many people are gonna watch this I can't
afford to make a mistake yeah I've read
yeah I can't right now I can't afford to
make a mistake Hatem means the final and
so if that was not the case they would
be making thousands of videos about me
saying look he doesn't even know Arabic
because Hudson doesn't mean final like
Malik and Malik you have Malik is a
killer of the Quran which means owner
yes yes it's true killer as at the Quran
I'm sure you're aware of this yeah so
you can recite them if you look at the
Quran you can recite for Tom Foreman
alhamdulillah blah I mean I marry Keo it
could be seal of the prophets
look cannot be a contradiction
look yeah when you have a killer like
that if you never be contradictory to
each other that means you're saying this
contradiction the Quran sorry look
there's the point is not preserved or
that is contradicting itself or you try
and bring out some new Arabic some funky
Arabic but in either three cases the
situation is one situation is the Quran
says it's the final prophet and there's
no way of bypassing that unless someone
does some kind of Co for you see what
I'm trying to say you have to say that
the finds are contradicting itself you
have says I'm preserved or you say the
Arabic I've got it completely wrong and
you give me some evidences from the
first 300 pre Islam show me that you get
aunt Alicia dead or the Lockhart's of
the Arabs and tell me that you know give
me some evidence that Hakim doesn't mean
you have to go yeah I'm finish is
anything you want to say to that
do you see does that make sense for it
makes sense but I we have like we like
we have some like Arabic dictionary
right yes we we only seem cotton but you
only believe in the seal of the prophets
like that that's that's the that's the
first the translation the first seal of
the process is find us
even I like are saying that right so I'm
a Muslim right regardless I are you a
Muslim that believes in the preservation
of the Quran yes all right so when I say
if I
I'm reciting the Quran now and I'm in
the prayer and I say Mele Chioma Dean
are you gonna correct me not Malik Malik
Malik means King but it's you know the
son cannot ten ways you can recite the
Quran four of them you can recite them
the word Malik oh now there's six of
them which is actually more you can say
Malik so if I say Malik comedy no they
don't mean the same one means honor and
one means King but we say as Muslims we
believe that Allah is the owner and the
king you can go on our scale in via MIDI
scholars none of them are gonna deny
that Allah is the owner and the king
because as far as I know they don't deny
the Quran they don't deny the
preservation of the Quran right and that
they will preserve through the crowds
right let's say that it is true right
yes let's say he's the last prophet but
then you guys now believe that you saw
will come down remember he's not a
prophet or are you guys gonna strip them
away of prophet he's gonna come back
when he comes back like all the prophets
the beginning brother all the prophets
America it's not just I say no one makes
a distinction look the day of judgment
is as real as this world all of the
prophets are going to be raised on the
day of judgment do you agree alright so
when they come back are they gonna come
back as prophets ah
now if they come back as prophets or do
you believe there's going to be prophesy
their functionality as a prophet as a
law giver as someone who has been
receiving wahi to guide the people that
has come to a cessation at their death
I'm given example it doesn't have to be
right and there's difference between
between what is the difference maybe and
so the point I'm making to you is this
is that the argument falls on his face
when we talk about okay he's going to
come back well all of the professor's
will come back even worse than this okay
you will be less knowledge Alistair all
Miraj when the prof
actually believe insufficient I
understand fine let's move on but the
point is on the day of judgment on the
day of judgment it's as simple as this
we believe all the prophets are going to
be there
now you asked it asking me well Jesus
will his thing is his placement as a
prophet be stripped away from I'll ask
you the same question all of those
people are going to be prophets but
their functionality yes
well not who's gonna be the leader of
them Mohamed Salah son I was laughing
but is it Mohamed Salah I said I was
gonna do so file and Cobra and so-and-so
fry the point is not about this is about
chronology you're saying to me because
you're saying this is the only argument
you really have now touching on straws
you left you're saying that look do you
guys believe in a second coming of Jesus
now that must that must mean necessarily
that there's another professor from
Mohammed well I'm saying we believe that
all of the profitable Mohammed in the
day of judgment Mohammed is gonna come
back as well then if all of them are
gonna come back they're gonna come back
in a different capacity because I'll
assess you for the word Nabi it means
you you know being given news or
something yeah you've been given news
now they're not coming back to be given
news and then deliver that news they're
coming back to be judged for example or
in the case of Jesus to make a judgement
okay they come back with specified rules
not with the role that they had before
so the point I'm making sure that the
verse see look you have to say it
yourself you and this shows I'm not
saying that it's about you bro I'm
saying it shows you you're willing to
leave all of Islam for Ahmadiyya because
you will intimate the Quran contradicts
itself yeah which would be impossible
unless I said not a godly word in order
to avoid the fact that the verse says
why it says which is it shows you it's
quite disturbing the point I'm making it
to you is very simple right the Quran
says that Prophet Muhammad is the final
prophet ha terminally
let's let it be there yeah that's how it
is
the stethoscope the scholar brother tell
him to come
please mr. saga Koopa come yes it's our
life
all right thank you thank you mom thank
you